[Musique]
on s'est vraiment éclaté c'est que c'est
un enfant dans un corps d'adulte c'est
un mec a pas de filtre donc c'est vrai
que tout et tout est possible avec son
personnage adam j'ai bien vu qu'elle
avait au moins 20 kg trop impuissant et
déjà perdu 10 ha ouais nan c'est pas
assez malheureusement et donc du coup il
sort ce qui sort ça lui paraît normal il
peut blesser des gens il se rend pas
compte
il n'est pas dans l'île et dans aucune
convention aucun code gétaz que tu vas
pas me chercher pour la famille fallait
évidemment je fais sujet est d'ailleurs
si tu as failli ne me plaît pas il ya de
très fortes chances que tu partes ce
soir très bas remarque il incarne
quelque chose qui est dangereux c'est la
bêtise absolue en même temps il reste
hyper touchant ce n'est peut-être même
ça qui est dangereux c'est qu'on les
aime quand même là on en a fait quelque
chose je pense
comparé à la version américaine ce qu'on
l'a emmené vers pourquoi il est si
débile pourquoi il est si nana et d'en
faire un truc vraiment touchant de
savoir pourquoi en fait c'est ce mec là
est un enfant dans un corps d'adulte
on comprend qu'il est qu il encore plus
haut qui j'ai écrit que malgré là qu'il
a eu une enfance horrible mais mon père
est parti quand j'étais tout petit et ya
ma mère m'enfermer dans la chambre à clé
parce que je te soutenons bull c est la
miss était dg vous hais les chaussettes
et des trucs comme ça c'est comme s'il
n'avait pas été éduqué marque s'agissait
pas je suis pas 32 non non non plus 60
ouais mais bien tassée et ça c'est pas
du tout imposer tout de suite que
jonathan je marque et il n'avait pas
très envie d'aller je voulais pas au
début je voulais être vraiment réal là
dessus à 100% qui se disait barack temps
est-ce que physiquement je suis vraiment
ce respect ce de bellâtre à l'américaine
dans la version américaine il a des pecs
comme ça il a les cheveux châtains c'est
un pompier je vois que les comédiennes
me disent tu tu le fasses jérémy aussi
les producteurs du méga c'est pour toi
je m'attendais planète dans l'histoire
mais d'ailleurs il s'est mis en forme
pour pour la série pour être le groupe
plus proche de ce jour du sud est avec
le choix vraiment le max beau gosse de
ce que je pouvais moi être ce qui est
quand même pas ouf
donc du coup je fais du sport de fou
j'ai perdu du poids
le sport c'est du bonheur du bonheur il
fallait que j'avais une z torse nu il
fallait que je sois un peu truqués au
final à la scène et a eu un peu de
retard dans le tournage trois semaines
de tournée
l'abrégé à l'arbre est bon quand ça va
ça va c'est potable
[Musique]
oui
le truc que j'avais dit à tous les corps
de métiers enfin tout cas qui s'occupe
du hm c'est tout ça j'ai dit je dois
être un playboy doit être super bien
sapé toutes les sables doivent aller au
maximum le soir pour la cérémonie ni
bijou est coiffé parfaitement sap est
parfaitement il faut que j'en jette faut
bien qu'ils aient quelque chose qui sont
un peu attrayant pour que les filles
continuent à vouloir être dans l'
aventure donc c'était ça le pari fou